la imagen siguiente tiene una área de 80
centímetros cuadrados cual es el ancho
de la figura así que aquí tenemos esta
imagen de una jirafa muy divertida
escuchando música y la figura de esta
imagen observa que es un rectángulo y
nos piden encontrar el ancho de la
figura el ancho de la figura y para
encontrarlo no tenemos una ecuación o
una fórmula especial para encontrar el
ancho pero lo que sí sabemos es cómo
encontrar el área de un rectángulo así
que usemos esa fórmula y veamos cómo nos
puede ayudar sabemos bien que el área
un rectángulo el área déjame no tardó
aquí de un rectángulo es exactamente lo
mismo que multiplicar al largo del
rectángulo y déjame anotarlo al largo
del rectángulo que multiplica al ancho
al ancho del rectángulo si multiplicamos
ambos lados de un rectángulo vamos a
obtener el área ahora bien sabemos que
la área es de 80 centímetros cuadrados
porque eso es justo lo que me dice este
problema así que el área es de 80
centímetros cuadrados muy bien y por
otra parte sabemos que el largo de esta
imagen es de 10 centímetros es lo que
hay desde aquí
acá ese es mi largo así que lo voy a
notar aquí el largo es 10 centímetros y
lo que no sabemos es cuánto vale el
ancho justo eso es lo que estamos
buscando pero es lo que sí sabemos es
que el ancho debe ser un número tal que
al multiplicarlo por 10 nos den 80
bueno pues ese número es 8 porque 8 por
10 es 80
eso significa que el ancho de nuestra
imagen es de 8 centímetros y ya con eso
acabamos este problema así que vamos a
hacer otro problema más y para eso
déjame quitar este problema de aquí y
vamos a traer el siguiente este de aquí
y dice un rectángulo tiene un área de 24
metros cuadrados
el ancho del rectángulo es de 4 metros
cual es el largo del rectángulo y en
esta ocasión no tenemos una imagen para
observar el rectángulo pero tenemos toda
la información necesaria por aquí para
resolver este problema de nuevo podemos
usar nuestra fórmula que dice que el
área déjame notarlo el área esta es
igual a quien bueno el área de un
rectángulo es lo mismo que multiplicar
el largo por el ancho el largo que
multiplica al ancho que multiplica al
ancho bien y vamos a usar esta fórmula
para resolver este problema y podemos
dibujar este rectángulo tal vez eso nos
ayudaría bastante a visualizarlo pero
estoy seguro de que podemos resolver
este problema sin ver el rectángulo
porque ya sabemos que el área es de 24
metros cuadrados
justo lo que me dice aquí que el área es
de 24 metros cuadrados entonces lo voy a
escribir justo aquí porque es el espacio
que cubre el rectángulo 24 metros
cuadrados y esto tiene que ser igual y
bueno su largo no lo sabemos es justo lo
que nos preguntan cuál es el largo del
rectángulo así que lo voy a poner aquí
pero lo que sí sabemos es el ancho eso
nos lo dicen aquí en el problema
el ancho es de 4 metros por lo tanto
vamos a utilizarlo también el ancho es
de 4 metros muy bien entonces el largo
debe de ser un número que al
multiplicarlo por 4 nos da de resultado
24 y bueno ese número tiene que ser 6
porque 6 por 4
es lo mismo que 24 entonces en este caso
ya podemos contestar que él
árbol de nuestro rectángulo es 6 y en
este caso estamos hablando de metros así
que serán 6 metros y ya con esto
acabamos este otro problema de lujo